hello my name is Mike Doty I used to be
the guy in Seoul coughing we appeared on
Howard in like 97 98 something like that
Howard dug the hell out of the our song
super bombon and to this day you know
about once every three years I'll get
like thirty five thousand tweets that
are like Howard mentioned the song again
so I think it his entire career he's
like four songs so I'm very stoked to be
among them move aside and let the man go
through let the man go through move
aside and let the man go through let the
man go through move aside and let the
man go through let the man go through
move aside and let the man go through
let the man go through through
if I stole somebody else's a wave to fly
um if I rose up with the Avenue behind
me some kind of herb some kind of moving
thing something unseen some hand is
motioning to rise to rise to rise to
fatfat you must cut clean you gotta take
the elevator to the mezzanine shop
changing its own super bonbon super
bonbon super bond on you fat fat you
must cut lean you gotta take the
elevator to the mezzanine chump change
and it songs if a bonbon super bonbon
super bunny
and by the phone I left in fear sheer
chance will draw you and to hear you fat
fat you must cut lean you gotta take the
elevator to the mezzanine chunk change
its own super bonbon super bomb on super
bomb on
two fat lot you must cut clean you gotta
take the elevator to the mezzanine Shan
Shan Janet's on super bon bon bon superb
and our super bon bon super bon bon bon
bon super bon bon bon bon bon
Bauval I let the man go let the man go
move uh
I let the man go let the man go move
aside and let the man go through you let
the man go through move aside and let
the man go through we'll let the man go
through
move aside on that the man go through
who let the man go through move outside
on the demand you let the man go through